hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einem kleinen quatsch video über die
jetzige situation im mega projekt also
die explosion und das die nation ic- und
simon jetzt abgehauen sind als outlaw
und ganzheit wechselnden das alles
gerade auseinanderbricht und zwar war
ich ja im urlaub und habe deswegen nicht
so viel mitbekommen und das einzige was
ich jetzt etwas mehr erzielt wurde war
halt das ist halt immer so kleinigkeiten
gab es streit zwischen brocken fans oder
sonnig und das liegt an der quali
darüber gesetzt hat um so was alles und
das irgendwie halt bei denen tnt unter
die druckplatte gesetzt hat simon ist
darüber gelaufen das heißt simon trifft
eigentlich keine schuld findig weil es
halt ein anderer war wie ich weiß nicht
wer es war keiner weiß wer es war bisher
es kommt paletten in frage aber das
jetzt erst mal relativ egal
die sache ist halt nur die dass jetzt
dna daraufhin natürlich gefragt hat wer
das war und sicher keiner gemeldet hat
und er daraufhin dann glaube ich sechs
gezündet hat und die sache ist jetzt
einfach die das dena jetzt verband wurde
sage ich mal aus der stadt so als
zusammen beschluss und das weil simon
ich beim haus auch noch eine menge weg
ist und bei dem rauch und com ist
natürlich zu recht sauer das heißt ich
verstehen damit natürlich komme und dass
simon danner und zornig handel setzt man
bei denen auch alles weg ist oder
zumindest viel bei denen das alles weg
bei den anderen beiden sehr viel dass
die jetzt abbauen und woanders was
machen verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht
so also ich kann natürlich verstehen
dass die alles erreicht haben quantum
rüstung alles mögliche mit technik und
magie und so gemacht haben
aber deswegen jetzt zum beispiel auch
halt ließ jetzt halt so ist kein bock
mehr auf technik und magie haben und so
aber dass das ganze dann das komme sich
jetzt die sachen zurück schieben kann
und wen ich hab das ja alles wieder
aufgebaut durch finde wenn ich die
einzelnen personen die meinungen von den
einzelnen personen hören
also zum beispiel simon bei ihm wurde zu
unrecht dass weggesprengt und er hat
keine lust mehr weil er möchte was ganz
normales machen weil er halt alles schon
erreicht hat evonik halt das gleiche wie
simon l dena erfurt zu von irgendwem
wurde sein haus zerstört und dann wollte
er sich natürlich rächen weil er nicht
wusste wem es war einfach 60 luft
gesprengt das war vielleicht eine zu
hohe rache finde ich aber sonst an sich
kann ich das eigentlich auch bisher noch
so verstehen und komme natürlich kann
ich am meisten verstehen weil er hat
nichts gemacht hat auf einmal die hälfte
von seinem haus weg und er möchte da
bleiben in der stadt weiter technik
machen
deswegen verstehe ich komme dann
natürlich auch ich verstehe alle
parteien irgendwie so ein bisschen was
sie nicht verstehe ist dass simon thür
onic und den er jetzt ganz weit weg
rennen von allen anderen die sind über
20.000 blöcke weg und sind jetzt outlaws
die jetzt nix mehr mit technik und magie
und so zu tun haben
ich finde da durch dieses megaprojekt
was von anfang an den sinn hatte dass
wir zusammen in einer stadt leben und
zusammen aufnehmen können dann mal
aneinander vorbeilaufen und jeder kann
auf dem wann er will das macht es jetzt
das bringt sitzen nicht mehr weil was
bringt es mir mit simon aufzunehmen wenn
der 30.000 blöcke von mir weg ist und
wir keine interaktion miteinander machen
können wir können quasi nur zusammen
quatschen wir reden quasi aneinander
vorbei weil wenn ich mit broken kam es
zum beispiel aufgenommen hat sind wir
zusammen um gelaufen amrum geträumt
haben gelacht haben das scheiße gebaut
haben da wieder was produktives gemacht
und tiefe lassen jetzt mal weg
aber man war halt so zusammen sondern in
seiner festung sage ich mal zusammen in
dieser stadt und das jetzt einfach
weglaufen das macht diese sind so was
von kaputt finde ich bei mega projekt
also das ist meine meinung und deswegen
schließe ich mich auch jetzt
mittlerweile vollkommen dagegen dass ich
ein auto werde weil es war so circa fünf
die fifty bei euch weil ich hab ich ja
gefragt ist eine menge kommentare jetzt
mittlerweile schon über 30 5000 oder so
die hälfte mal die soltauer werden weil
das in ganz witzig war wärmer so eine
kleine abwechslung mal ganz woanders und
die andere hälfte main bleibt die uhr in
der stadt macht technik das total
scheiße was den uns abgezogen haben die
vig da die behörde haben die ganze
zugeschrieben man kann da natürlich auf
boden der tatsachen
na ja deswegen ich möchte eigentlich in
dieser stadt jetzt über bleiben bei den
ganzen anderen weil ich möchte dass es
mega projekt so weitergeht wie es
begonnen wurde und nicht das einfach den
chronik und simon dann einfach weglaufen
vor den ganzen sachen die jetzt auf die
warten und quasi sich einfach irgendwo
dann verschachteln und das haben wir
halt am arsch der welt
ich meine da könnten die theoretisch
dennoch einfach mega projekt von vorne
anfangen und sich ein neues grundstück
holen sag ich mal
und dann halt noch mal von vorne
anfangen und mit halt gar keinen sachen
und dann wäre die sache geritzt aber das
geht zu weit weg laufen und so ich finde
das zerstört das alles bei was bringt
ein server wenn wir alle jeder wurden
vom anderen 1000 blöcke entfernt das
bringt es nicht ich finde es besser wenn
wir alle in einer stadt leben und basta
also das ist meine meinung dazu ich
werde bestimmt kein autor das ist mir
jetzt egal was jetzt in die kommentare
schreibt ich hoffe ich akzeptiert das
einfach weil ich mit finde diese stadt
gehört dass die zusammen bleibt und
nicht dass die hälfte dann irgendwie
wegläuft und autor wird also die
entscheidung autos werden sie nicht
einfach nur doof und ja also ich werde
mich jetzt weiter mit technik und magie
befassen und dann mit den anderen leuten
dann aufnehmen und mit denen er zornig
und simon auf jeden fall megapark denke
ich erst mal nicht mehr weil ich habe
keinen streit mit denen unter so alles
cool zwischen uns aber ich finde es
macht keinen sinn mit denen aufzunehmen
wenn die 1100 1000 blöcke fängst sind
also das ist einfach nur und na ja also
das war erstmal mein statement zu der
new und mein statement allgemein zum
megaprojekt zur zeit und ich hoffe ihr
akzeptiert das und ja wahrscheinlich
vielleicht werde ich heute am noch
streamen also ich packe ich erstmal den
livestream linken beschreibung da könnt
ihr mir folgen und da werde ich dann
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen megaprojekt
zocken und so was alles und neuer dann
würde ich sagen wenn es euch gefallen
hat könnt ihr an daumen hoch geben wenn
ich dann halt nicht und schreib mir mal
eure meinung in die kommentare und naja
also gebt mir bitte jetzt will man
meinen daumen hoch wenn ihr wirklich
auch der meinung sei dass die stadt
zusammen bleiben sollte nicht einfach
wegrennen sollten gibt einfach den
daumen runter wenn die komplett dagegen
welt und sagt ja soll auch jeder sein
eigenes ding machen
also dann würde ich sagen sehen uns dann
morgen wieder oder heute abend im
livestream und dann